okay The Punisher season two you guys
are fantastic in this season really
enjoyed it I want to ask for you your
character what would you say is the best
part and the biggest challenge joining
the Marvel series um I mean the best
part was just getting to tell a story
unlike one that I've ever told before
and getting to be a part of this crazy
crazy world that I've never even
imagined myself being a part of and it's
just exciting every single day coming to
set was just it was amazing and the
relationship that I formed and the
biggest challenge I would say would be
um it was uh I mean I'm always thinking
this but it's just like how can I make
this as good as it possibly can be as it
can possibly be it's because you know
the show was amazing season one I was
like can I just come in and make it any
better and like you know however I can
do that I really wanted to work as hard
as I could to make that happen
yeah and then for Frank camp castle in
season one you say I no longer have a
war to fight but we know that there's no
show so what is your what are you
fighting about in season two what do you
think it's uh you know I think he's
really forced to face his own nature and
forced to face the reality of who he
truly is and that's at the kernel of
what why Frank Castle I think has been
fascinating in comics for for over four
years now you know
he knows this all is starting within
himself you know who is the real Frank
Castle is he the the father and husband
in in the suburbs or see the soldier you
know standing and thicken in blood and
mud and and and and death you know and
and where where is he more at home who
is the real him and and you you know you
know what I've always found fascinating
about him is he's not looking for peace
he's not looking for quad he's not
looking for happiness and I think he's
going through the motions in the
beginning of the season and and he's
he's trying that out he's flirting with
it um and but he finds out real quick
that that's uh that's not what he's
meant for and I think deep down he
doesn't think he deserves it and that's
that's what that's something that I find
really tragic but but but but really
really fascinating and compelling mm-hmm
Amy's character in season two you're
around the same age as Frank's daughter
who had passed how can we see your
relationship evolve in this season how
what happens
um it's I mean the the way it starts off
is kind of funny because by the end of
the season you're like how is that even
how they were interacting um you know I
think Amy is at first you know kind of
terrified and confused about this
lifestyle that Frank lives but you know
comes to see that it's you know that's
just who he is and I think their
relationship throughout the season he
becomes a protector to her and she you
know becomes kind of in a way like
somebody that he he can entrust and
trust and you know just talk to you as
like a like a daughter figure you know
so it's it's yeah it's really special I
like that and rumors are swirling is
this the final season of The Punisher I
see your foot starting to tick a little
bit waiting for hits no I think you know
you know what I know
we will be that we will be the last to
find out but will the end of this season
season two will it will it end what you
feel like it's over
or will it kind of leave you open for
something more I mean I think that I
think the way that the season was
constructed I mean I think like all
these these shows are kind of
constructed I mean it's not it's an it's
an ongoing story the story of frank
castle will always be ongoing it's a
reason you know we did we didn't start
this thing and we're not gonna end it
you know we this is this is something
that we have borrowed from the many many
iterations that have come before us and
have fascinated comic book readers and
and members of the military members of
law enforcement it's a character that
that has huge resonance and we just we
just borrowed them for a little bit and
showed our version of them and and our
version of this world and we will
definitely not be the ones to end it
yeah good answer
you